to me the federal emergency management
at fema
is providing millions of gallons of
water and millions of meals
and direct assistance to uninsured
homeowners to repair the damage
burst pipes caused to millions of homes
across the state
the public assistance that comes with
the disaster declaration ensures that
mayors and county officials can find
shelter for folks
in need and keep them safe and warm this
is in addition to the more than 125 000
blankets fema has also made available
to storm victims so children and
families don't go to sleep cold
fema working with the defense logistics
agency and the army corps of engineers
from the defense department has made
generators and diesel fuel available to
hospitals
and nursing homes and other critical
facilities to keep the lights on
and speed power restoration along its
way
many local military bases are helping
efforts to distribute water and food
fuel and blankets all across this state
and i especially want to thank the
service members for
helping your fellow americans in time in
need when we have a problem we always
call on the military domestic or foreign
no matter what the best in the world
and i know millions of texans have been
impacted by the disruption of community
water systems as a result of the power
outages
the environmental protection agency has
deployed mobile drinking water labs in
houston
san antonio and fort worth to test water
so we can get the
so you get boil water advisories lifted
and gets safe drinking water flowing
through those faucets again
there's more but let me say this we're
not here today as democrats or
republicans
we're here today as americans the
american leaders with responsibility all
of us here in this parking lot
responsibility to all the people we
serve when a crisis hits our states
like the one to hit texas it's not a
republican or democrat is hurting
it's our fellow americans are hurting
and it's our job to help everyone in
need
look out for one another leave nobody
behind
that's what we've seen today in our
visit after our briefing on the storm
relief we stopped by the houston food
bank
uh that's also doing god's work
incredible operation
just like everyone else here in this in
the vaccination center
they've done thousands of people
thousands of people
it makes us making a fundamental
difference in the
safety and security of people the more
people get vaccinated the faster we'll
beat this pandemic
that's why one of my first steps and my
first goals
as president was to announce that i was
going to get 100 million
coveted vaccine shots administered in my
first 100 days
because of the people behind me and
others america would be the
is going to be the first in the country
perhaps the first in the world to get
that done
and i'm proud to say we're halfway there
50 million
shots actually i i was telling the
congressman earlier i carry a little
card with me
and a list every day the number of the
actual number of vaccines that have been
administered
as of today five as of last night
503 587
every single one matters in just 37 days
weeks ahead of schedule we're weeks
ahead of schedule
even with setbacks from the winter storm
we're moving in the right direction
look in the last six weeks we've gone
from
six million shots right before we took
office in total
to 12 million shots per week now
we've increased vaccine distribution by
70 60 of the people over the age of 60
of people over the age of 75 have
received at least one shot
close to 50 of the people over the age
of 65
got at least one shot and you say why am
i focused on that well it's especially
important because people over the age of
65
account for 80 percent of all the cova
deaths
80 percent roughly 75
of the people who live in long-term care
facilities now have gotten their first
dose
and those cases are at the lowest level
since the reporting began
back in may we're making this progress
because of all of you
the federal government and the states
are working together
along with public and private partners
it starts
with supply we work with vaccine
manufacturers pfizer and moderna
to ensure we had enough supply to supply
all
adults in america by the end of july
and we discovered the vaccine
manufacturers though weren't getting
prioritized
when it came to securing supplies they
needed
to fix their problem and not being able
to go more rapidly
so i use the defense production act to
speed up the supply chain
for key equipment that's already helped
increase vaccine production
last week i toured the pfizer vaccine
manufacturing facility
in kalamazoo michigan it's incredible
the precision the safety the pride
the sense of purpose everyone involved
in that facility
and we've all seen the news about
johnson and johnson vaccine
is just the third safe effective vaccine
and it's out it's they've approved it
today
we're going to use every conceivable way
to expand manufacturing
of the vaccine the third vaccine to make
even more rapid progress in getting
shots in people's arms
here's what else we're doing we're
increasing the number of vaccinators
the people putting the valves one thing
to have the vaccine nothing to get in
people's arms
we brought back retired doctors and
nurses by executive order allow that to
happen
we've already deployed more than 1 500
professional
medical professionals you see during the
natural disasters from the
from fema are commissioned core from the
department of health and human services
and the defense department including the
national guard
and we're lining up thousands more we're
also setting up more places to get
vaccinated
and today as of today we provided 3.8
billion dollars
to states territories and tribes
to create hundreds of new vaccination
centers and ramp up
existing ones we're providing personnel
and equipment
and we're covering the cost for states
including the use
of their national guards here in texas
it's meant millions of dollars and
hundreds of vaccinators
working at community vaccination centers
and three mass vaccination centers
in arlington dallas and right here in
houston and the other side here
to vaccinate thousands of texans a day
tens of thousands overall i want to show
the american people the extraordinary
effort
being made and undertaken and the most
difficult
operational challenge this nation has
ever faced logistically
it's remarkable about 6 000 doses a day
here
folks who are eligible can call by phone
sign up online for an appointment
drive in stay in their cars get a shot
in and out
in a very short amount of time requires
massive logistical coordination
and critical federal support from fema
and the national guard
to work with cities and states and the
houston texans stand
up this kind of site vice president
harris and i did a virtual tour of a
similar
vaccination center in arizona one nurse
one nurse there said she talked about
the shots talking how many they were
getting in people's arms
and she said she felt like she was
administering and get this
a dose of hope a dose
of hope we're working with governors
across the country to stand up
and lend federal support to hundreds of
vaccination centers
from stadiums like here to community
centers to houses of worship
large parking lots delivery places doses
that hope we can get in people's arms
as quickly as possible i've also sent
millions of vaccines to thousands of
local pharmacies
over seven thousand to make it easier
for folks to get the coven 19 vaccine
shot like they would a flu shot because
people are comfortable going to their
local pharmacy they go there for their
flu shot everything else they trust the
pharmacist
and they're getting likely to go
here in texas that includes 500
pharmacies
across this state like walmart and cvs
including 50 pharmacies here in houston
and for the folks who didn't live near a
vaccination center or a pharmacy
we're deploying mobile clinics to go out
to those neighborhoods in rural areas
where people are unable to get to the
centers
these are special vehicles of pop-up
clinics and meet folks where they live
and where they don't have the
transportation to get the shots which
they'll be launching
very soon here in houston that mobile
those mobile units as well as dallas
arlington and across the state we've
also started to send
vaccines directly to community health
centers to help the hard to reach
folks in cities small towns and rural
communities
in black latino and native american
communities that have higher rates of
cover 19 infections and deaths
than any other groups here in texas
we're already partnering with 12
community health centers
in 10 cities which have combined sites
at over 100 locations
across the entire state we're going to
save people's lives as a result of these
round-the-clock efforts
in five weeks america has administered
the most shots
of any country in the world that's great
progress
it's also true that while covert 19
vaccinations are up
covert 19 cases and hospitals around
but i need to be honest with you i said
from the beginning
that roosevelt who said i'll shoot you
straight from the shoulder
you can handle anything as long as
you're told the truth
cases and hospice hospitalizations
could go back up with new as new
variants emerge
and it's not the time to relax we have
to keep washing our hands
staying socially distanced and for god's
sake
wear your mask wear your mask it's not a
political statement
it's a patriotic thing to do some of our
progress in this fight
is because so many americans are
stepping up and doing these things
and the worst thing we could do now
would be let our guard down
and here's another critical point we're
going to hit a phase in this effort
maybe late april early many predict
there will be ramped up vaccine supply
and we'll have administered shots to
most of the people who really are eager
to get them
and those who've been able to get there
but at the same time the warning is
there'll be people who live in hard to
reach areas
who can't get the shots and there are
folks who are hesitant to take the shots
we all know there is there's a history
in this country
of subjugating certain communities to
terrible medical and scientific abuse
but if there's one message that needs to
cut through all this
the vaccines are safe i promise you
they are safe and effective listen to dr
fauci listen to the scientists to
develop them
through extensive and rigorous review i
did
and i took my shot publicly to
demonstrate to the american people it's
safe and effective
to address this challenge we're going to
launch a massive campaign to educate
people about the vaccines
that they are safe and effective and
that they can go and get those shots and
be
good i'm going to close with this this
past year
has been one of the most painful years
in american history
as i said we've lost over 500 000 lives
of the virus
500 000 moms and dads
husbands and wives sons and daughters
staring at an empty chair
the dining room table the kitchen table
friends
neighbors co-workers and over the
country
all over the country where the loved
ones who uh
are gone they're gone empty
empty feeling in your chest like you're
being sucked into a black hole in your
chest
but all over the country where loved
ones once sat
there's an empty chair and folks look
there's so much we can do as you see the
broken hearts and the families that have
been left behind
there's nothing partisan about this
virus it's too long we've allowed the
virus to divide us
i met today with governor abbott senator
cornyn
conservative republicans i'm a
democratic president
we disagree on plenty of things there's
nothing wrong with that
but there are plenty of things we can
work on together and one of them is
represented
right here today the effort to speed up
vaccinations
we're not giving shots to democrats or
republicans i say it again we're giving
shots to americans
and all across the country we've got
members of the armed forces fema
volunteers retirees fellow americans
working around the clock to give these
shots
and they're building on the work of
scientists researchers doctors
and nurses and my team at the white
house which is coordinating all this
is first-rate none of this has a
partisan tinge or a partisan element to
it
this can be a great american achievement
being the only country
in the world to reach 100 million shots
in 100 days
this could unite us as a country to
vaccinate america to protect america to
heal america
and i know we can do this why because i
know america can do great things when we
do it together
i know my family spent a lot of time
here in houston by the way
at hey john eddie how are you buddy i
didn't see you there
and houston at md anderson when our son
beau was being treated for glioblastoma
before he passed away
just yesterday i saw m.d anderson
announced his joint
he joined four they joined four other
major cancer hospitals helped break down
the silos
that make real progress in this effort
difficult
now they're sharing data and information
that wasn't going on
four or five years ago we're gonna beat
cancer
i know we will i've said it before and
i'll say it again
there's just one thing one thing
i could be known for as president i
would be the end
the president who enduring his era ended
cancer as we know it
but then last week guess what
we also landed a rover on mars
we led by a nasa team in pasadena
california
a rover carriage instruments developed
by a team here in houston
that'll be used in the mission of our
time and our dreams imagine
we talk everybody's been so down the
last
number of years about what america what
can we do who we can do anything
american can do anything and now we see
the images that are truly stunning
battling covet beating cancer going to
mars
if there's one thing i know about
america is this
americans never give up they never give
in
they never cry uncle they just struggle
innovate and they preserve
and persevere we're going to get through
all of this i promise you
we're going to do it together together
god bless you all and may god protect
our troops you're the best
we can do all this guys i promise you we
can do this
nobody in the world can compete with us
when we're together thank you all so
very much
all right
thank you
thank you
three
okay
uh